well i want to get to that but you bring
up a very fascinating point
to me your liberal friends
you know you're you're died in the wool
liberal or you're mainstream middle
they have made what we're dealing with
possible yep
because they've never stood up against
it
and now they're being threatened by it
like everybody else
uh some of them see it bill maher and
some of these other people naomi wolf
although she's not a liberal she's a
radical but nonetheless they see it even
glenn greenwald sees it he's
left with people are saying uh oh
yeah uh oh you remember stalin went
after trotsky
these people are not nice i mean mal
wiped out all of his lieutenants this is
the way it goes
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
lawyer a best-selling author
and a broadcasting legend mark levin
finally
welcome to the reuben report david is a
great honor to be with you you know how
much i admire you thanks for having me
well i'm thrilled to have you here what
do you consider yourself
first because you've written what like
800 best-selling books i mean
new york times number one they couldn't
have been happy about that i mean what
what
really are you sort of first
you know uh my attitude about this is
i use every platform i possibly can to
advance the cause
of liberty constitutionalism
and unalienable rights since i was a kid
so i moved into radio first which i
enjoy the most
i love to write because it really gives
me time to
think about things you know to really
uh focus think things through
it's not a fast pace like radio and so
forth and uh and of course television i
like too because a lot of people are
very visual
unfortunately they have to look at this
as punim as we say
but nonetheless i try to use all these
formats to do exactly the same thing
in a different way and i think our
country's in desperate need
of as many paul reveres and thomas
paines as possible
so that's my attitude yeah i don't
really know well
well you are one of the paul reveres and
i want to get into some of the stuff
that you've been ahead on because
you've been kind of warning about what's
happening forever
but um let's just back up for a sec
because i realized this morning
as i was doing a little research i
actually don't know that much about your
childhood
and i sense you you strike me as sort of
you were conservative at five
is that is that possible is that right
well it started in a log cabin
with the guy behind you i guess back
there yeah now that's correct
um look here's the thing i never liked
authority
it's a funny thing i never liked
authority i didn't like classrooms i
didn't like how strict they were
i was beyond it i was ready to do my own
thing as a kid i was ready to read my
own books check history we didn't have
the internet and so forth and i
that's exactly what i did and uh
uh i didn't understand why i had to do
stupid things
just because that was the regiment that
i had and so
i think that had a uh sort of an
intellectual or philosophical effect on
me unwittingly
and as i got older i really did distrust
what people were telling me not that i
was
paranoid or anything it's like i wanted
to check it i wanted to i wanted to make
sure i agreed with it
and sometimes i'd say well what is that
all about i don't agree with that
what about this and
my general philosophy is live and let
live that's pretty much my general
philosophy and get out of my face
that's that's that's pretty much it and
uh it's gotten a little bit more
complicated since then
but um i think i was a libertarian at a
very young age and more of a libertarian
conservative and then i kind of coined
this phrase or made it
public again which is constitutional
conservative 20 years ago i said because
i was referring to the constitution all
the time
but yeah we would uh around the dinner
table around the breakfast table
there were two brothers and my parents
we were very
talkative we would debate the issues and
i'll tell you something dave
none of us were liberals even though
we're all jewish and so none of us were
liberals
my father who passed away my mother who
passed away
um my father told me voted for goldwater
in 1964 now how many jewish people do
you know who voted for cold war in 1964
and i said to him
dad why did you do that and he said and
i'll quote him
i knew all the [ __ ] they were saying
about goldwater couldn't be true
so i voted for him and that was kind of
my attitude at a young age and
uh and you know and then you add meat to
the bone you start reading philosophy
and history which i
i can't tell how many books i've read
economics and that sort of thing and you
develop a
you know way of living in a way of
thinking yeah let's let's dive a little
deeper on that
because you mentioned sort of
libertarian to conservative to
constitutional conservative
what was it as you know i i've sort of
brought the phrase classical liberal
back and that that was what my book was
about and people always say to me well
dave is there any really
meaningful distinction between classical
liberal and libertarian so actually let
me start with that
do you see any meaningful distinction or
or have the labels and words all become
sort of muddled in in modern times
well they can be uh but they're in the
same they're in the right
area in other words not right philosophy
in the correct area
you know i've always uh libertarian
conservative
libertarian conservative conservative
libertarian
it's like scalia and thomas
they both wrote opinions sometimes they
would agree sometimes they would
disagree
but the way they approached the issue
was what is key
what is it that drives your thinking
what are your principles behind your
thinking
and so i was once asked i think was by
ben
as a matter of fact on his show he said
when you interpret the constitution do
you do it from a libertarian point of
view or conservative point of view or
how do you approach it
i said well libertarianism and
conservatism are
philosophies interpreting the
constitution is interpreting the
constitution
that is you're not supposed to bring a
philosophy to it
you're supposed to try and discern what
the framers
meant and what the words meant at the
time
so i don't get into this am i
conservative
liberal libertarian when i interpret the
constitution it's the constitution
so why do i call myself a constitutional
conservative
i have many libertarian beliefs
um but i call myself a constitutional
conservative because
of the thinking and the arguments and so
forth that people understand that went
behind the constitution
itself the debate said we don't want a
mob we don't want a monarchy we don't
want these things we don't want direct
democracy we don't want factions what do
we want we want a republic
and they developed the most fascinating
and i hope lasting uh republic that man
has ever created
so are there differences well of course
they're differences
uh libertarians fight with conservatives
all the time you know guys like
hayak and mises they had no stomach for
conservatives
uh these the austrian score on the other
hand milton friedman did
uh and he's one of my great heroes and
so uh
we're going to argue over libertarian
versus conservative i'm
fine we're going to argue over
americanism versus marxism
that's a whole nother i think we're
going to be okay on whatever the
marginal
libertarian conservative differences are
so let's put that aside but you know
every every way that you just sort of
answered that question
what sort of sat beneath it was you have
great reverence for the founding
documents for the founders
for our history and it seems to me we
live in a time
where that is just i mean you actually
said hope that was
meaning that you hope that these things
will still matter but we in essence live
in a time where
we're we're erasing all of that at a
rapidly increasing pace
yeah and i'll get into this a little bit
i've been thinking about this too we are
and why is that why is it that the world
we're told in america now has begun
1619 and not 1776
critical race theory uh critical
immigration theory
um the uh the attack on capitalism with
the d
growth movement the climate change move
all these things what are they
why did they kind of just spring up in
the last 20 30 years and especially
our focus this year and last year and
the reason is
and i'm going to use the word these are
marxist-based ideologies
if people understand karl marx they
understand his writings they understand
his background
and i've studied very very thoroughly
for a project i'm working on
he was a journalist people don't even
know he was a journalist he had many
articles that appeared in the
new york sun he was a
classical liberal for a period of time
and then something happened he saw
things and he abandoned it
and he developed his ideology really
based on rousseau and hegel and those
guys
and he just he just moved it towards
materialism
and he just he was an angry man he was a
poor man he always relied on his lawyer
father
and his friend angles to subsidize him
um and i think to my and by the way
people don't realize
for 30 40 years after he died nobody
cared about marx
except american progressives who were
fixated with him
um but all that said i
uh i'm of the attitude that
with the early progressives dewey wilson
crowley all these guys and more
they said basically we need to change
education in america
it's not enough to teach mathematics and
history and english without
a social construct without an
understanding and putting it in a
cultural perspective
and that's what they did they
fundamentally altered
public education which became bigger and
bigger and then they altered
colleges and universities you know back
then as i recall about six percent of
the population
graduated from college today it's about
34 35
and so they felt as elites
and so-called intellectuals that is
where they can make the biggest change
and they have
they've fundamentally altered the way at
least half the country looks at this
country
and as you know marx wanted a clean
slate
so our history is to be attacked our
history is to be degraded our history is
to be rejected
so whereas somebody like me and you we
look at our history in ancient history
and all history in order to try and
figure out what what is mankind about
where should we be or
are we doing the right things does this
make sense they don't
so antifa black lives matter leftist
period
they attack american history they reject
what the framers did
i'm going on here a little bit dave but
you know no no
the slow march through the institution
so what do you do then so
if we're at that strange place now and
you know 35 of these of the kids that
now go to college
that so now you've got 35 as opposed to
six percent what do you say that was
just a couple decades ago in essence
um well that's an awful lot of
brainwashed people coming out of these
schools
what do you do in an age of social media
and in an age of
you know a culture war
we have to begin to use the left's
tactics against the left
i believe this is very strong i never
used to believe this
i used to preach free market capitalism
i still believe in it
all these other things and they're very
very important
but tactically we're gonna have to get
active
we're gonna have to do things we've
never done before
because marxism is a constant revolution
conservatism or constitutional
conservatism
is a stand in place and so
they're always on the move and we're
always on defense
if we're doing anything at all i look at
it with the democrat and republican
party it's not a precise parallel but
the democrat party is always
breaking windows the republican party is
always sitting in rocking chairs
you know just watching it and so
this has to change now i can't control
the republican party
um and i think that's why a lot of
people like trump because
wittingly or not he would break windows
when they would break windows and
wow there's a guy finally who's fighting
for these things
but also um i think more and more of us
in our individual lives
are going to have to become activists i
don't mean violent activists i mean
activists i
uh in everyday things that we do where
we choose to buy things
um when we talk to neighbors form
groups to go to school boards do all
these sorts of things
start pressuring our legislatures
where we have friendly legislatures to
pass laws like they do in florida to
address
big tech we need to be on offense we
need to bring litigation
we need to throw as much against them as
they throw against
us and do everything we possibly can i
mean the nation was founded
by men who who
who took a very activist role in their
lives they were pushed to a point
and of course the difference between the
marxists that we deal with now and
us is they want to destroy our society
yeah you know that that's interesting
the french revolution they wanted to
destroy their society the russian
revolution the communist
the chinese rebel they all wanted to
destroy their system the american
revolution wanted to preserve our
society
and change the government um what's
happening here
is we're up against street marxists or
mobs or whatever you want to call them
that want to destroy our society
and uh are demeaning our society as
the crt folks you know we're white
dominant society so everything related
to it
is bigoted and racist which is so absurd
and uh i just think we need to stand up
and say enough
we need to push back everybody has a
different role in this life
some people electricians some are bus
drivers some do what we do and so forth
but all of us in some role in our life
whether it's our purchasing power
whether it's school board meetings
churches synagogue we've got to speak up
we've got to be heard and we've got to
organize
that's what i keep telling people
nobody's coming to save us except
us that that really is it how worried
are you though that
with you mentioned big tech that with
the acceleration of information
that by the time say we get to the
midterms the amount of destruction
that these guys will be able to do
whether it's packing the courts
changing the electoral college
immigration
i mean the litany of things that i know
you're worried about that it will be too
late that in some ways that the founding
documents won't even be able to stand up
to it because there is a wash coming
that that seems oddly unstoppable
it's a great point a lot of the
firewalls in the constitution have been
breached
um it's been a long time coming i've
written about it over the course of 20
years or so they've been breached by the
courts they've been breached
and so committee you know c-o-m-i-t-y
that sort of thing used to exist you
know you run an election you lose all
right i lost
now there's another election coming now
the game is with the number
i lost an election i never intend to
lose an election again
um and your question is do we have time
i don't know but we need to fight like
hell because i can't i don't know what's
going to happen in two years five years
and six years i know it'll happen
if they win and we lose it's going to be
totally different country and people are
going to be
sending their kids through
indoctrination mills and all kinds of
terrible things are going to happen in
this country where people probably still
don't believe it's possible it's
possible it's happening
and that's one of the key things people
need to understand this isn't theory
this is reality it is here and now this
is going on
this is repression that's taking place
people it can't happen in america
it can happen anywhere and you know
we've had we had these firewalls in
place
many of them have been breached many of
them are controlled by the wrong people
and so that's the reality and we have to
push back and do everything we possibly
can
is the fundamental problem that the
firewalls only work if we can sort of
agree that the rules are the rules and
now we're fighting
something that doesn't agree that there
are rules or or that the rules were set
up by evil patriarchal racist
you know whatever you want to call it
you hit the nail on the head
freedom without virtue doesn't you know
it's not freedom and
that was exactly what the founders said
you can't just have freedom you have the
people who are going to follow the rules
you have to have people who are going to
have integrity
you have the people who don't want to
burn down the place you know so
you have an election fair election you
win you lose okay next election
it's not i'm going to change all the
rules to make sure i win
and if you don't agree with me you're a
jim crow racist
so the democrats have decided to take on
the
uh posture and the substance of the most
radical elements within the party
and that's why you say you know you
watch
this chauvin case and you watch the
riots and everything and you watch
either the silence of the democrats
or the celebratory tone of the democrats
and even though black lives matter and
antifa aren't official wings of the
democrat party
in many ways the useful idiots at the
democrat party
and vice versa they feed off of each
other
the democrats need to stir the pot
they want their base to be angry they
want their base to coalesce around them
they want to use the opportunity to
change the country whether it's the
voting system whether it's the
immigration system whatever it is
and that's exactly what they're doing
and so
when you hear what biden said a couple
of days ago
after uh the verdict you know this shows
america systemically racism
who the hell are you talking to what do
you mean america's systemically racist
i'm not chauvin i don't even know what
the hell you're talking about you don't
even know what you're talking about 40
years ago you were white supremacist
now today you're telling us we're all
he's a very evil man who's always been
about joe biden and so forth then i
watch kamala harris get out there and
say
the nation's systemically racist
i don't need to tell you but to
underscore the point
there are millions of people trying to
get into this country yup
they're not coming from sweden they're
not coming from norway they're coming
from central and south america they're
coming from africa they're coming from
the far east they're coming from
asia these are minorities these are
people of color
by the millions they want to come into
the united states because we're
systemically racist
i mean how absurd is this whole debate
and mark none of them are leaving this
country
it's an it's a very confusing thing wait
let's let's back up to biden for a
second because
i had i still have a couple friends uh
who are liberals that will still talk to
me some most mostly privately they won't
talk to me publicly anymore
but a lot of them kept saying don't
worry dave after the election don't
worry
biden is the firewall they didn't go
crazy bernie
they didn't go crazy elizabeth warren
biden will stand up against this stuff
and now that trump is gone
it will be easier for us good liberals
to fight the woksters well in the few
months since this has all happened i
have watched these people fold like a
wet paper bag
um did you have any illusions that biden
might stand up to some of this stuff or
did you just fully
believe that he was going to go down
this route no matter what well i want to
get to that but you bring up a very
fascinating point
to me your liberal friends
you know you're you're died in the wool
liberal or you're mainstream middle
they have made what we're dealing with
possible yep
because they've never stood up against
it
and now they're being threatened by it
like everybody else
some of them see it bill maher and some
of these other people naomi wolf
although she's not a liberal she's a
radical but nonetheless they see it even
glenn greenwald sees it he's
left with people are saying uh oh
yeah uh oh you remember stalin went
after trotsky
these people are not nice i mean mal
wiped out all of his lieutenants this is
the way it goes
right they're not just coming for levin
anymore now they're looking at me yeah
the french revolution raspier he went
after everybody and then he got the ax
so the revolution is a nasty piece of
work
but we still don't have the liberals
they're either completely silent
or they just think this is another cycle
we're going through and so forth will
all come out of it just fine
we need the liberals we need to unite
we need to have people who aren't them
the marxists are trying to destroy this
country we may have
disputes over this little issue or that
little issue
but if you love this country put the
damn disputes aside we've got to unite
against this they are attacking every
aspect of the bill of rights
our unalienable rights they are
attacking businesses they're attacking
minorities they're attacking private
property rights they're attacking
our free speech they're attacking
freedom of assembly go down that list
and it's happening very very fast as you
point out
as for biden wait can we
can we just stay on that for just one
second because because i'm fascinated by
this and as you know i wrote a book
defending
liberalism but do you think that there
is a fundamental
flaw in liberalism that has stopped
these people from doing that because
that's the uncomfortable conclusion
that i've come to at this point to me
the flaw is look what you did was very
brave
but you can live with yourself you said
you know what i'm over here
but there's too much weird stuff going
on over here i don't agree with all this
it's too weak we're losing this we're
losing that i gotta move over to some
extent with these other guys who get it
i don't have to agree with them on
everything but fundamentally
they're civil libertarian i'm a civil
libertarian i believe in civil rights i
believe in individual liberty that's
what i believe in
that the left believes and group this
group that even liberals
we don't even see the aclu anywhere
anymore where the hell is the aclu
they're in on this now it's not that we
don't see them they're in on it yeah
and that's the thing so to me what
liberals
traditional liberals have done is
they've made it easier
for the hard left the marxist left
they've helped pave the way
for them and i think some of them don't
know what to do about it it's like well
i don't really want to say that the 40
years i've lived
are flushed down the toilet that's the
other hand these other guys are kind of
ugly over here i don't know whether i
want to join them
you know um and they're going to get
rolled over
with the rest of us if they don't stand
up it's odd i i haven't found you people
that scary
since i've joined you there's nobody's
that they always warned me that levin
shapiro glenn beck these are scary
people prager very scary
and yet we're very easy yeah we really
are
uh yeah no do you think that there is
something connected to belief
that plays a role in all of this i i've
sensed that with my liberal friends
that come from a more purely secular
position
on this that their their underbelly is
just
too soft it's it's too sort of we
accept everything so yeah we'll kind of
go down the road to hell with you
when you get it from faith or get it
from somewhere else
if you don't believe in existential
truths
and if you don't believe in look
the golden rule the ten commandments is
there a problem with the golden rule and
the ten commandments i don't think so
well those are the fundamentals really
when you when you when you write them
down that's the fundamental
you look at the declaration of
independence the reason why that
document is so incredible
these men they knew about
judeo-christian history
many of them were practicing christians
these men knew all about the
enlightenment the reformation they
studied it
they studied the aristotle and cicero
and
you name it they knew they were well
educated men
and they put together this declaration
of independence they put everything on
the line
everything on the line so look at that
declaration of independence
abraham lincoln cited the declaration
over and over and over again during the
civil war
and one of the things he said that a
country's founders who could write such
a document
and leave it to their progeny to fix
this issue of slavery
were magnificent men and abraham lincoln
did more
for black people than any other human
being
ever in the united states ever
ever he loved this country he embraced
the constitution
he was disgusted by taney the chief
justice of the supreme court in his
ruling
uh in in the dred scott case but he
always defended the constitution
defended the founders making the point
we wouldn't even be here as a country
but for what these men did flaws and awe
and they told us
we can't fix this issue of slavery but
our children and grandchildren are going
to have to
because endowed with what
in doubt our rights unalienable rights
that applies to every single human being
on the face of the earth
you know when jefferson originally
drafted the declaration there were five
drafts
he put a provision in there that the
british were forcing slavery on the
college which they were
they abolished slavery but they're
extremely active in the slave trade they
were making money off it
we had borders that were very porous we
couldn't really and they kept
moving slaves selling slaves into the
united states and one of the things
that jefferson had said in there even
though he'd been a slave owner
he said this is one of the reasons and
the some of the southern states
blocked it so
you know something like that they
embraced the declaration
they knew they couldn't resolve the
slavery issue they eventually did
resolve the slavery issue like no other
country on the face of the earth no
other country had a civil war over
slavery we did
and when you listen to people today
it's just that none of this ever
happened but what i was going to say is
this
about biden real fast we can come back
and sure
getting older so my memory you're doing
just fine you're doing good
biden has always been a nasty piece of
work
when he came into the senate he coddled
up to
james eastland and john stennis two old
southern racist segregationists eastland
was even a plantation owner
who said the most horrific things about
black people
biden called up to these guys biden
opposed
bussing a lot of people opposed bussing
including black people didn't want their
kids bust 25 miles in each direction
but biden's language was different he
used the language of the racist he
talked about
uh he didn't want his kids going into
these uh jungles and so forth he would
racial jungle that's what he said racial
jungle he would
he would say the kinds of things that
the racists would say
and then later he was tough on uh crime
you know he
i was the author the crime bill used to
say of course he doesn't say it anymore
i don't have a big problem with that
crime bill by the way crime went way
down but that's a whole other story yeah
then he shifts his position because he
sees that's not popular and now
you know he wants to be bigger than fdr
and obama and
and uh and johnson and that's all he
cares about
biden is a very dumb guy he's a he's an
egomaniac he's always wanted to be
bigger than really his capabilities
that's why he plagiarized as a young man
that's why he stole words from robert
kennedy and neil connect when he was
running
back then we actually had standards so
that knocked him out of the running for
president
yeah people don't know that he
plagiarized and that actually got him to
step
down from the democratic primary i think
like 88 or so
today it would be like who cares um
so he's all he's always he's always been
that way but he's always been for biden
and that's what you're seeing now biden
uh
didn't give any indication that he was
going to be like to the left of bernie
sanders
every piece of radical legislation
radical executive order
radical policy that he can put in place
he's putting in place bar
none yeah bar none i feel like we're
getting hit in a thousand directions
here with this guy
right so well that's not really
ideological
it is it is it is a personality flaw
but but do you think he's driving it at
this point that's the part that i can't
figure out it's like i don't think he
really believes in all of this stuff
you know i also think he has cognitive
problems and a whole slew of other
things
but it's like who this is what everyone
asked me the time well who's the driver
of all of this radical leftist stuff
it's obviously not 47 years in
government biden is it
is it obama like who's behind the thing
do you think at this point
you know what i think it's all that i
think he's look at his staff
look at the people throughout the
government it's like pick the craziest
bastard you possibly can for every one
of these positions
uh you want you want a guy at the
treasury overseeing guns then pick the
biggest
anti-gun guy you want somebody looking
at civil rights we'll pick a woman who
hates white people and goes on and on
about white people and so forth
mark we got a gay guy doing
transportation come on that's
qualification enough isn't it come on
look there's two departments they always
give the guys they don't care about
transportation and hud so i wouldn't i
wouldn't but here's the thing
i think he's told them who he wants to
be and what he wants to do
i don't think he's there working in the
weeds and all this stuff i think they're
giving him this stuff and he's happy to
sign it
i think he's there over legacy he wants
to create a legacy
for himself and he'll do almost anything
to do it
and that's what he's doing and he's also
by the way we haven't touched on it
he's creating enormous dangers overseas
he's always been an incompetent when it
comes to that and other things you know
he sat on the foreign affairs committee
signed on the judiciary committee to the
important committees
and uh he's he's been so wrong so often
that i am very worried that but before
he goes we're going to be in some kind
of war
if not with china with russia i think
iran's going to have nuclear warheads i
think this world is going to be an
absolute disaster and mess because of
him and because of the people he's
appointed so this is a very serious time
indeed it is all right let's
shift i could do i could actually just
do history even getting away from
politics i could do history with you for
hours but
let's happy to do let's shift a little
bit from some of this because i want to
talk about the big
tech portion of all of this because
you've been very outspoken but not only
outspoken you actually
put your money where your mouth is in
that you are not on twitter anymore you
actually tweet it out i'll read it for
everybody
we'll put the tweet up on january 8th
you wrote
i have suspended my own twitter account
in protest against twitter's fascism
i ask all my followers to join me now on
parlor and rumble
uh obviously a couple days later parlor
servers were blown up
they are now back at least on the app
store temporarily
um but you're not happy about this you
are you are wary of centralized power
whether it comes from the government or
from big tech
i left facebook and i left twitter
but i spent six weeks telling everybody
on facebook and twitter i'm leaving
the end of the year here's where you can
find me
so i wasn't foolish enough to cut my
throat
and to do facebook and twitter favors
until i was ready to do what i wanted to
do
right so we have over 5 million
followers on parlor now
we're starting to build up rumble uh we
have what five six hundred thousand over
there
i believe in entrepreneurship you i'm
i thank goodness that thank god that we
have these other platforms that are
willing to compete
um i am not going to participate
in um the fascism
that is being demonstrated by these
oligarchs i'm just not gonna do it
they started giving me the scarlet
letter over and over and over again i go
what are you doing
well this third party well they pick the
third parties they're left-wing third
parties they're not
i said you know what i'm not going to
participate in this you're stealing the
data
from millions of people who follow me
and i'm telling millions of people
to unfollow you now some do and some
don't
but they've come over to these other
platforms
and i feel the position i'm in i can
help some of these other platforms i'm
not an investor in any other i'm not
that there be anything wrong with it
but i'm not and i i tell my folks look
we
this is what i was talking about when we
open the show you got to put your money
where your mouth is we can't just talk
about these things
i'm not opposed to other people staying
on there because they need them and they
want them and they want to build up what
they
everybody's like i said everybody has
their own role
my role is as i told you earlier get the
hell out of my face
you're gonna you're gonna start giving
me a scarlet letter every time you
disagree with me
i'm done with you it's that simple yeah
so what do you think
the role of government is related to big
tech this is where the libertarian
beliefs that i have have been really
pushed to the end you know
you know it always comes down to okay so
build your own internet
and it's like well what should the
government do i mean i don't think
government
regulators wandering into google are
going to do anything i've heard
more liberty-minded people say well at
the very least
break them up use some antitrust
generally i don't think the force of
government is going to do much good at
all i mean is there
anything that you think can be done here
there's several things i don't know how
effective but it's worth trying in my
view
and i think they're principled things
number one in 1996 as part of the
communications act legislation
they got a special privilege which
should be taken away there's no reason
why they should have immunity as a
public platform
from lawsuits based on what other people
post and based on what they post
nobody else gets that except the media
and that was a
perverse new york versus sullivan
decision in the 1960s that's not in the
constitution either
yeah are you worried though if you took
230 away from them that in essence they
would just start censoring everybody
because they would say hey
whoa we're suddenly liable for all this
stuff so now it's actually going to
increase censorship at some level
they'd also face 10 000 lawsuits which
have no
hope of winning right now so
i think they'd have to say you know what
um
we either go out of business or we let
everybody on there and that's their
defense when they go to court
your honor we can't keep track of all
this stuff
because that's the thing if you're going
to act like you can
then you have responsibility on your
hands if you say to the court
we can't keep track of all this we are
in effect a public forum
and so we can't possibly be responsible
for all these things i think they'd have
a better shot at it
my problem is this it's not
free market not only do they get this
protection they are an appendage of the
democrat party
and so they've made this abundantly
clear how do we know we know
through their censorship who they
support and who they don't we know what
zuckerberg did with 400 million dollars
to help the democrats in democrat areas
of the country
where they put money in grants gave them
the front groups the front groups work
with the local governments to get out
the vote
mark they fortified the election that's
what they told us this was to fortify it
they fortified their party and and to me
we can't pretend that's not happening so
much of our speech now has to be
funneled through big tech
i mean they invite us on these sites
since 1996 people come on they're
friended they're followed
they're stealing our data they're making
billions and billions of dollars from it
and they are controlling our speech
and they're controlling our speech
because in 1996 they were given a pass
and here's the other thing being a
libertarian and all
there's a lot of things that could grow
out of this that we can't possibly know
or even imagine right now
so if they really want to be part of the
marketplace then they got to play with
all the other
boys and girls out there who don't have
these protections
and then let's see how they do and maybe
they'll break up on their own
and maybe something will come and
replace it right now it's an oligopoly
with protection
so there's no way to know so my attitude
is this isn't an issue of free markets
i'm not trying to spin this i thought
about it a lot
these people are denying us liberty
who are these people and why are they
doing what they're doing
and so when you politicize this thing
and you put ideology in this thing and
then you go around
banning people and censoring people and
as i say
you know putting a scarlet letter on
these people that's a whole different
ball game
if they were honest and fair about all
these things i could care less
but uh but they're not and you know
brempos and his group are keeping track
of all these people who are being
hammered
it's so obvious what's going on um
so my attitude is you got a special
protection remove it whatever happens
happens
it uh things can grow out of it
entrepreneurs
can develop out of it and look even
parlor
they tried to destroy parlor and they've
even threatened them now apple says you
meet our standards or you're out of our
store
so they're blackmailing them i don't
think we can have that
yeah i'll give you another silver lining
that i've been telling people about all
this which is that as these companies go
further wow go further left
they're bringing in these diversity and
inclusion departments
and in essence they're going to hire
based on quotas as opposed to hiring the
best engineers and the best managers
and thus that over time will also cause
them to collapse
you know uh you would hope so but that
could be a long time from now
so you never know i didn't say how fast
i just said yeah right
it's a little a little bit of a silver
lining you know what's interesting they
know more about us than we know about
them
they know everything about us they have
access to everything we've ever written
on on the on the uh on their platforms
access to anything we've ever purchased
they share the information with each
other they have
third-party data collectors that do
exactly the same thing
1996 nobody uh imagined such
things so it's a different entity now
and
i'm not one of these who say um you know
we broke up exxon so we are
standard oils a way to break up these
guys i'm one of those who says if the
any trust laws
apply use them if the states need to
come up with laws like
ron desantis in florida federalism
use them they've picked the fight with
us
we didn't pick a fight with them it's
like the rest of these corporatists
we're just going about our business
they're running around putting labels on
us
because the democrat party wants them to
put labels on us and that's exactly what
they're doing
they picked this fight we didn't pick
this fight we got to fight back
when you see guys like ron desantis do
the the
you know big tech bill that he just
signed or you know now he's signing this
uh i forget exactly what they're calling
but this basically making a stronger
distinction between protesting and
rioting
he's doing a bunch of bills that i think
you know for sane people
sort of makes sense um you that must
sort of
make you feel validated in oh federalism
does
kind of work and in a weird way the
crazier that biden
and the federal government gets it
actually is bringing some of the states
back to the roots and back to the way it
was supposed to be
that's exactly right and
you know i'm one of the early advocates
of convention of states
[Music]
this is a movement to use article 5 of
the constitution the second amendment
process
to get our constitution back the
constitution has been amended
over and over and over again through the
back door
through court decisions through
legislation
through regulations it's being shredded
and and that would include the bill of
rights
and separation of powers these are our
protections
and so i've been saying i wrote a whole
book on the liberty amendments
originally i was against it
and then i said wait a minute as i study
it more
the framers were fought that's why it's
in the constitution and the states
signed off on it that's why it's there
and so i
i i've been arguing that we already live
in a constitutional convention where the
left controls
what the constitution says over and over
again and is changing it
and i've heard a lot of some objections
to it where people say well if you have
a convention anything can happen they
don't understand the process
no anything can happen it's like a it's
it's uh
you have first of all you have to have
uh 34 states sign off on
legislatures that's not easy we have 14
right now
then you need 38 states to ratify so
it's not like somebody's going to sneak
something
through or anything like that or you can
have a rump convention
and not only that under the rules as
we've studied this
it has to be focused on a few issues
and the states and the the state
legislatures not even the governor
send the delegates and that
fire alarm was there and it was put
there by george mason
two days before the end of the
constitutional convention
he said and i paraphrased but accurately
what do we do if congress becomes
oppressive
the only out for the states is a
revolution
we've got to provide something and so
this was what was proposed
this this state convention process
madison was originally hostile to it
but then he embraced it you know when he
embraced it
he embraced it when states started to
nullify laws he embraced it when
states were thinking of breaking off
before they actually did
and he pointed to that and he said
rather than destroy
the union look at this we have article
five
you guys we can get back together it's
just the states having a meeting
we can get get back together have a
discussion on what it is we want to
change rather than burning down the
whole republic so in a letter in
particular he embraced what he had
opposed
as a way of trying to stave off the
disintegration of the union
so it's very important i don't know how
much luck we're going to have but i told
you before
every front we got to confront our
friends yeah so it's interesting because
we have
these options in front of us to save
some of this stuff but you know
look i'm here in l.a i'm in california
it is beyond
imagination governed the wrong way and
hopefully we're going to recall newsome
but knowing this state will bring in
someone who's even worse
but but what do you do in a case because
you said disintegration which is the
phrase our friend ben shapiro uses
what do you do in the case if okay
california just keeps going off the deep
end
keeps spending keeps doing everything
wrong then the good people of texas the
good people of florida in particular who
vote properly have balanced budgets
don't have income tax make sensible laws
related to policing
and all of the rest of the stuff i could
see them all becoming extremely
resentful
of having to bail out those loony
californians every now and again i
cannot believe this is the position i
find myself
in at this point you know relative to
five years ago but i get it now
the more the civil
society collapses the more the
constitution frays
and so i worry about these things i mean
the left is pushing so hard their foot
is so far down on the gas pedal
there's going to be a reaction one day i
don't know what it's going to be
i don't know how it's going to be i'm
sure it's not going to be pretty
but people are going to say all right
the hell with this law-abiding stuff the
hell with this comedy stuff the hell
with the civil society
they're destroying my schools to destroy
my kids education destroying my job with
open borders
representative government is a joke
they're taking half of my
income i've had enough i don't know if
that'll cause states to break away again
i don't know what the role of law
enforcement will be in the military i
don't know
but i am deeply concerned that the
democrats have no idea
how many fuses they're lighting but with
their
official and unofficial relationship
with these marxist entities
uh including within their own ranks so
it's very concerning you're going to
have the law of the jungle you lose the
civil society that's it you talk about
california
you know i lived in california very
briefly and
the governor was pete wilson and you had
duke magen
and of course you had ronald reagan
those guys couldn't get elected today if
their lives depended on it i remember
george h.w bush won california
when he ran for president on reagan's
coattails
and i also remember this isn't that long
ago and i also remember
experts so-called saying it's going to
be a long time until the democrats can
win back the presidency and they would
show
they can't win california they can't win
texas they can't win florida they can't
win
so they can't win so what do the
democrats do
okay we're going to open the spigot no
border we're going to change we're going
to change
this state and what pelosi
from san francisco wants to do is take
california and apply it to the entirety
of the rest of the state that's where
she gets her mindset you know that
that's what that's literally what she's
saying you're not making that up i mean
that's what she's telling us
and if they do that it's over we can't
win
how do you know what one party rule is a
very dangerous thing
it's dangerous thing because people
don't like it
so as somebody that's been doing this
for
a couple couple decades longer than i
how do you
stay sane throughout this because i
think we're also watching so many people
become
and there's many reasons for it relative
to lockdowns and losing their jobs and
the general disarray and chaos but just
people are depressed you know when i do
my daily show i always make a point of
trying to
not be alarmist not be hysterical end on
a positive note tell them that
this isn't everything but in a weird way
right now it's starting to become
everything even though we don't
you know our salvation is not through
politics and yet and yet it's at our
doorstep
how have you managed to kind of not go
bananas as someone that's been warning
about it and then it still
keeps coming well some people think i
have
who knows but that said
sometimes i gotta walk away from it um
i'm almost done a book i'm writing on
it's very difficult
and i say to my wife i can't i got i got
to step away from this for two days it's
just too depressing
um i uh when i do my radio show i wear
my emotions on my sleeve
why yeah why are you passionate why do
this i said well because i don't work
for npr i'm a real human being you know
i do what i do
right but it is difficult but people
need to
find solace in family they need to
one of the things i do you know they say
miserably misery loves company it's so
true
i think about those men who fought at
the revolutionary war
and how they suffered
and i think about things that other
human beings have gone through like the
holocaust
or world war ii the battle of the bulge
or d-day
or the korean war which was a horrific
war that never gets talked about
or the vietnam war i think about these
things
that other human beings have gone
through
and they've gone through a hell of a lot
more than i have
and so that helps me
mentally focus
it also helps me fight because i say if
these people are going to put their
lives on the line or if they're going to
die
and uh and their ancestors are have to
speak up on their behalf
then we have to do something more than
whine and complain about these things
look at this country this is such a
fabulous country
it is it's such a diverse country
you know i've talked to so many people
i've interviewed so many people
and uh shelby steele in particular
something he said to me
just rings every day so true
you're free you are
free do whatever you want to do with
your life
nobody's stopping you except you and you
don't know what to do with your freedom
you're free now in how many countries
can you say that
very few and when you look at how we
send our men and women off to war to
defend people who look differently than
us
who have different religions in us in
some hellhole
somewhere for whatever the reason is
and then you call americans
systematically racist
this is blasphemy
this is appalling when you look at this
country
where we have the highest rate of
interracial marriage in our history
over 20 percent when you look at our
the diversity in our police forces our
diversity in our military the diversity
in our public figures and acting and so
forth and so on
when you look at millionaires and
billionaires of all colors
the idea that this country is
systemically racist
we embrace a capitalist system the
capitalist system is incapable of racism
it's literally incapable of racism i
give this example let's say go to a
diner
let's say somebody else goes to a diner
and they're a bigot
and they get eggs and bacon and milk and
whatever it is
they don't know who what chicken who
owned that chicken
farm could have been a black family they
don't know
where that bacon came from they don't
know so he may be a bigot
but capitalism is not bigoted and
capitalism and liberty go hand in hand
it doesn't
mean you can't have capitalism in
tyranny like you have quasi-capitalism
and heavy-handed tyranny in china
but for liberty you have to have
capitalism
and this is very very important to
understand so when there's an attack on
capitalism it's really an attack on
private property rights liberty
your intellectual and physical labor it
is an attack on you
so i look at this country and i say to
myself these people who keep calling it
systemically racist there's really two
kind of people who do this
it is the uh the self anointed or
self-proclaimed elite
or it's the uh or it's the uh the
the sort of marxist ideologue in the
street
the vast majority of people in this
country i don't care if they're black
or they're brown and they're what
they're not pining for marxism
no they're not planning to eliminate the
cops
they don't hate the united states
military
so uh that is a positive just think that
most of the people we can get to them
you can explain things to them i think
most of them will still be with us
i think that was mark levin's opus you
you
you took us out beautifully i'm going to
ask you to stick around so we're going
to do one thing
for my locals exclusive i'm going to ask
you what mark levin does for
fun so i'm going to let you think about
that for about 10 seconds
i'm going to thank you for doing the
show we're going to link to all your
everyone knows where you are and who you
are and all that good stuff but we're
going to link to all that below
and i just want to tell you it's really
an honor and a pleasure
and i hope we can do this in person one
of these days
that would be great and the honor and
pleasure is mine you are absolutely
terrific
thank you thank you if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our
full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell